madame monsieur bonsoir la france
touchée par la grâce du football
traverse est elle une phase d'euphorie
une étrange fièvre disent les
sociologues fait d'un sentiment national
joyeux et multiraciale les centaines de
milliers de supporteurs qui célébrait
mercredi soir au delà de tous les
clivages sociaux
la victoire des tricolores donne la
mesure de cet enthousiasme communicatif
et voilà que maintenant l'assemblée
nationale porte sur sa façade les
couleurs de la france en finale
sébastien guibert à la location la
cérémonie se veut solennel un grand cri
du coeur s'est affiché ce matin sur un
mur de l'assemblée nationale allez les
bleus allez la france
encouragements symbolique à l'heure où
la nation vie pour certains des jours
historiques
quand la france se rassemblent elle peut
gagner et que quand elle gagne elle est
rassemblé et ça c'est extrêmement
car il flotte dans l'air comme un
étrange parfum d'ivresse immense bonheur
collectif et spontané qui ne comble pas
uniquement les supporters de la première
heure la demi finale france croatie par
exemple a fait vibrer plus de 20
millions de téléspectateurs parmi eux la
moitié pratiquement étaient des femmes
cette coupe du monde se savoure donc en
famille entre amis parmi une foule
d'inconnus autour d'un drapeau tricolore
devenu emblème de fierté étendard de
force et la vraie le sentiment
d'appartenance pays et tous ensemble
alors qu'on a cherché à diviser l
lescure certains à pleurer de bonheur
très bonne nouvelle politique
la cote de popularité du président de la
république et du premier ministre n'ont
d'ailleurs jamais été aussi élevée dans
les sondages popularité et
reconnaissance voilà bien ce qu inspire
aussi l'équipe de france acclamé à son
retour mercredi soir à clairefontaine
des joueurs de football perçus comme des
symboles nationaux de vaillance et
d'enthousiasmé